so wait do you have you because SNL
you've been at 30 Rock quite a bit so do
you have any advice for me I love the
building the building is dope the whole
underground situation where of the
holidays you're going to it's going to
make you hate Christmas no it won't I
promise it won't no it won't I want to
revisit this I have two Christmas albums
I want to revisit this okay cuz that
tree and that traffic and that that gets
crazy I have performed at it several
times I love Christmas all right I am
the person that annoys you in your
family you're like oh they're vomiting
Christmas again that's fun like that's
me I have a whole village I set up at my
house all right well maybe you
won't I'm going to make it worse here
like no I love it so much but I I heard
that you use men's restrooms if the
girls you're just like no yeah that's
another thing I was going to tell you
the bathroom on eight is a good place to
poop okay I think that's important when
you work somewhere no you got to know
yeah we actually have it's so hilarious
on our floor there's one single bathroom
that you can can use and then there's
the one that you know Community
everybody and it's like the single you
know what everyone's doing when they
walk in I pass by reception I'm like
that that's right yeah Mama's got to go
I like when the stall door goes all the
way down to the feet so people can't see
the feet and they don't know how long
you've been in there yeah I don't like
when the feet are exposed you have a lot
of pressure when you poo okay yeah I'm
just like everybody does it I don't care
look you walked in here this is where
I'm supposed to be doing it like true
yeah that's on you I'm going to FL go
I'm polite I'm polite I have used men's
restrooms though because when you go to
a restaurant and I don't care get mad
about it men but like I I am upset
because there's never a line there
there's never a line yeah and it's
actually kind of C it's clean meaner cuz
you know why every woman walks in
thinking your nail and it there's pee
all over the seat it's like that's not
helpful and if you do that you clean it
up ma'am you know what it is though like
like with the squat
yeah but what information isn't out
there is that you got to aim here's the
bigger thing so has anyone tried to go
you're welcome America has anyone like
they sell you Spanx and they're like oh
man there's a hole so it'll make it
easier no we're so
cool watch out for that bathroom on
eight everybody at 30
[Music]
r
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home